[MUSIC PLAYING]
DIANE GREENE: Hey, Paul.
PAUL DAUGHTERY: Hey, Diane.
DIANE GREENE: Nice to see you.
PAUL DAUGHTERY:
Great to see you.
DIANE GREENE: Yeah.
I first heard of
Paul because he's
a board of trustee at the
Computer History Museum.
And then whoa, he's
the CTO of Accenture.
And I've been
getting to know Paul.
And I found out he started
out as a programmer-- software
engineer-- went on to
become a computer science,
entered the PhD program-- took
a little time out at Accenture.
And bang, 30 years later,
you're still there.
I think you and [INAUDIBLE]
may be the only two
people in this facility that
have never worked anywhere else
but where you're currently
working, outside of academia.
Tell me, how did that happen?
PAUL DAUGHTERY:
Well, I got into it.
First, I was at the
University of Michigan.
And one day-- I vividly
remember the day
when [INAUDIBLE] computer
showed up on campus.
And I saw those and said,
this is what I'm going to do.
And I got hooked on software
and computers at that point.
And I was going to go
into a PhD program,
as I talked to you about.
And I had a mentor
that said, go get
one of your business experience
before you get your PhD.
And I very strategically went
to the placement office and went
down the list, and
started in the A's.
And I work for Accenture.
[LAUGHTER]
And I thought it'd be one
year of coding COBOL and being
miserable with that, and then
going back to the PhD program.
I showed up on my first project,
which was a driver licensing
system for a state
government in the US,
and COBOL, IMS, DB/DC, and
my worst nightmares realized.
And I had a smart
group of folks I
was working with that came up
with an approach to say, let's
not code this thing.
Let's model it in
Smalltalk as objects.
And let's generate the
schemas for the database
and generate the COBOL code.
And it'll be
verifiable, and it'll
be a better way of doing it.
And we did that.
And it just turned
me on to this idea
that we can use
very innovative--
and that was 1986-- use
very innovative technologies
like Smalltalk,
even at that stage,
to solve real-world problems
and bring innovation
to results close together--
and got hooked on it.
And I'm still here now.
DIANE GREENE: Lucky Accenture.
So 30 years-- you've seen a lot
of transitions in technology.
So where would you
put cloud in that?
What was the tipping point?
And also, when did
you at Accenture
decide Accenture should
embrace the cloud
and start building solutions?
PAUL DAUGHTERY: For
me, it's economics.
If you look at economics,
you can figure out
what's going to happen.
And you and
[INAUDIBLE] and others
talked about this
already this morning.
But we had a fundamental belief
going back almost 20 years ago
that compute,
storage, and network
costs were going to go to zero,
asymptotically approach zero.
And that's what's happening.
And we believe that
as that happens,
you'd have things like
the cloud happening,
even though we didn't call
it cloud at that point,
and would have things
like IoT happening,
because you either
centralize for power
or you distribute with
small devices at the edge.
And so we have been
investing and driving
in that direction for
a long period of time.
And then about 2008, we
looked at it and said,
there's a big commercial
business around this
that we can form.
And you can see the
slide up there, I think,
that talks about the
evolution of technology
that you and I
talked about, Diane.
And what we saw was the
ability to really form
a big business around cloud.
So we launched a strategic
initiative around 2008--
said, let's get
serious about this.
And that's grown into being
one of the biggest and most
successful parts of Accenture,
which is our cloud business--
so over 30,000 people,
20,000 projects completed
in driving cloud.
And then about two years ago,
we saw this pivot, I think,
that many in the audience
have probably seen,
and that some of the speakers
have talked about today,
where we believed
about two years ago,
we saw that public cloud
first was the way to go.
We started shifting our focus.
We had been doing a lot
of public cloud work.
We said, that's
the way to start,
and let's just use that
as a starting point.
And we've been driving on that
mission for about two years.
And that gets us to
where we are today.
But the important
thing, I think,
and where it comes
to Google is, is
the cloud is really a
starting point, in our view.
And you can see all the waves of
innovation that are happening.
And what that means for
people running businesses
is you need a platform where
you can innovate faster.
And all the innovations--
machine learning,
artificial intelligence,
and innovations to come--
are why you need the
cloud as the foundation
because no business can innovate
fast enough on their own
without tapping into
the power of a cloud,
like what we've put together.
DIANE GREENE: Getting the data,
getting the mobile access,
bringing it all together.
PAUL DAUGHTERY: Right.
DIANE GREENE: It's a big deal.
PAUL DAUGHTERY: Yeah,
it's a big deal.
It's a big challenge
for the enterprises
to do it fast enough, given the
pace of technology [INAUDIBLE].
DIANE GREENE: Right.
Right.
And the other thing I
was talking about today
is getting into this exponential
curve of having impact,
and how we feel working
with our partners,
working with our customers,
we're now able to do that.
And we've been in the
cloud for over 16 years.
But I mentioned as
you were coming out
that we're now announcing
our partnership where
we're going to bring
solutions to our customers.
Can you tell me a
little bit about that?
PAUL DAUGHTERY: Yeah.
No, we're very excited
about the partnership
that you and I have
been working on.
And for me, our business is
about bringing innovation
to customers to help them
transform their businesses
for the digital economy.
And when we look across
everything you've talked about
and laid out-- and my
compliments on the way
you've laid out the story--
it's really fantastic with--
DIANE GREENE: Oh, good.
PAUL DAUGHTERY: --Google
cloud and the positioning.
DIANE GREENE: It's true-- real.
PAUL DAUGHTERY: It's real.
And we see a
tremendous opportunity
to bring all that technology
together collectively to really
help transform business.
And that's
fundamentally what we're
doing through the
partnership we announced.
So when you look
at Google Cloud,
you look at apps, the
analytics, look at ML,
at Android, Chrome, Maps,
all the pieces together--
Tango-- you look at the
transformative power
of the business,
that's what excites us.
And so we formed
the partnership.
And we're launching an Accenture
and Google Joint Innovation
Center to bring things
to life for customers.
We're forming an
Accenture-Google Joint Center
of Excellence to
build those solutions
and develop solutions.
And we're focusing on a set
of solutions and products
that will help clients construct
better digital experiences,
will help transform
the digital culture
within their
organizations, and then
bring better digital
tools to help
them manage in their business.
And it's very exciting.
DIANE GREENE: Any
specific examples?
I think it's so cool
that you're doing
both Android and the
cloud, and the apps
in this sort of broad
array-- the machine learning.
PAUL DAUGHTERY: Yeah.
There's a number
of great examples
that I get really excited about.
One of the ones I get
particularly excited about
is something we're calling
Retail Trend Watcher.
And Retail Trend Watcher is--
it combines some unique IP
and research we've done around
something called the customer
genome, which is a unique way
of understanding the customer.
And we're putting
that on Google Cloud.
And then we're combining a
lot of other capabilities.
So we're tying in the Vision
API so that we can do things
like go to Pinterest and
find images and pictures
and categorize-- get the
item/product classifications
and things.
And we're adding the
natural language APIs.
So we go to Facebook and find
customer comments and sentiment
and those sorts of things.
And you put that all together
with the ML-- the Machine
Learning, the API-- to do
the new neural modeling
to then do forecasting and
trend prediction of what's
going to happen going forward.
We think this is just a
transformative tool set,
and a great solution
for retail customers.
DIANE GREENE: We're
going to give you
an honorary PhD for doing that.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL DAUGHTERY: I
could use one of those.
Thanks.
DIANE GREENE: No.
So another interesting thing
I learned about you is you've
been really paying attention
to the trends in the workplace.
We saw with Airbus, here they
were analyzing these satellite
images with people by hand.
It took a long time.
It took a lot of people.
And then they applied
machine learning.
And it really didn't take
so many people, or very long
anymore.
Some people are kind of
saying the workplace is
getting disrupted.
I know you talked about that
at the World Economic Forum.
And you really take a
very optimistic view.
I actually share it.
I wonder if you could talk
a little bit about that.
PAUL DAUGHTERY: Yeah.
I'll just give you the
summary, and starting it
by saying that I agree with
some others who have said today
that artificial intelligence
is the big thing that's
going to transform business
over the next 20 years-- bigger
than anything else we've seen.
And the way we've done business
in the 20th century, which
is the way most of us
are still doing business,
just isn't going to work
anymore going forward.
So we have this
tremendous transformation
of business powered by cloud
and powered by the innovation
that we're talking about.
And that's certainly going to
create a lot of disruption.
But it's really going
to create growth.
And we just released
a study yesterday
that's out there,
available on our website,
where we did a modeling of what
the economic impact of AI is,
and the business impact.
And what we showed
with this study is
that we believe that there'll
be a potential doubling of GDP,
which in the US would mean a
growth from 2 and 1/2% to 4
and 1/2%, roughly, which
could be $8 trillion
of added economic output in the
economy, if the potential of AI
is realized-- similar
results in Japan and Germany,
and most other
countries we looked at.
And the underlying
reason for that
is that we believe AI drives
increased productivity
of up to 40% for individuals
and people and humans,
depending on the jobs you're
doing, because it's people
plus the technology
coming together,
allowing people to do what
they do best more effectively.
So we believe it's
a tremendous story.
It creates economic growth.
It creates growth
for businesses,
growth for economies,
and better opportunities
for people going forward.
DIANE GREENE: And
it's good that we're
teaching every
kindergartner how to program
so that as they get up
there, all people will
be participating in this.
PAUL DAUGHTERY: Will be
better-- that's a big thing.
If you don't do the right things
from an education perspective--
and it needs to
start early-- then
we won't have the
workforce prepared well.
So that really is critical.
We're involved with
a lot of initiatives
to make sure that's the case.
DIANE GREENE: But we definitely
don't have enough people
to-- very opportunity-rich
world we're
living in-- very exciting.
PAUL DAUGHTERY: Yep, many times.
DIANE GREENE: Well,
thanks a lot, Paul.
This is great.
PAUL DAUGHTERY: Thanks, Diane.
[APPLAUSE]